the jurogan experience so how did you
learn how to
do all this stuff was it trial by fire
were you learning how to use all this
i mean i don't call it ancient equipment
but mechanical equipment to figure out
yeah yeah secret is to begin
just start yeah i mean so sexton
where the [ __ ] does one learn how to
operate
a sextant and then navigate in the ocean
uh yeah just i would you know i started
uh
you know me and friends got a boat and
um we started fixing it up and
making a lot of mistakes and then you
know started taking some trips and then
i lost yeah i got a lot of lunch i took
a solo
trip from san francisco to mexico and
back
uh on a little 27-foot boat with no
engine
and whoa how long did that take a few
months
yeah and the way you did it did you stay
close so i can see the there's
the shore so if everything [ __ ] up i
can kind of swim
yeah well no you can't swim uh i learned
that lesson too no why
it's um i mean the closest i ever
came to death in my life i was just in
the bay
in the san francisco bay i was on a boat
that capsized and um i was
probably 2000 yards away from shore and
uh
i almost drowned and i i mean i didn't
make it to shore and um
yeah it's just the water so cold you
know you didn't make it to shore
no yeah it's a long story i was like um
i a friend of mine was living in san
francisco and he wanted to learn how to
sail
and i was like you know what you should
do is you should get like a little boat
like a little sailing thing you know and
then you can just anchor it like off the
shore in this
area that no one cares about and you
know you can sort of experiment with
this little boat and so he started
looking on craigslist and he found this
photos for sale for 500 bucks up in uh
up in the north bay and uh every time we
called the phone number
we got an answering machine that was
like hello you've reached dr
ken thompson honorary i'm only unable to
take your call you know and we were like
what is that like honorary
fake doctor is he like a judge a
chiropractor you know like
what is it yeah and so finally we got in
touch with this guy we go up there
and it's this the kind of situation
where like we pull up and there's like
the trailer that the boat's supposed to
go on and it's just full of scrap metal
and you know and you know this guy comes
out he's like oh yeah this is the
trailer
um we were gonna do a metal run but if
you want the boat you know we'll take
the
the metal off you know and we're like
okay you know and he's like taking us
around
he's like okay the mast is over here and
it's like under some leaves and you know
it's like and then
you know the hole is in the water here
in and it's he has like a dock
behind his house and the tide is all the
way out so the boat's just sitting in
the mud you know
and i'm like well how do we get this out
of here he's like oh you'd have to come
back at a different time
uh you know and then you take it over
there and we're like you told us to come
now like at this time you know what
anyway so we go through all this thing
you know and any and you know my friend
who knows nothing about votes it's like
all right moxie like what do you think
should i get this and i was like okay oh
and we were like so what's
you know doctor of what he's like oh
self-declared you know we're like oh
okay
he's a self-declared doctor honorary
self-declared doctor you can do that i
guess that why not
it's just an answer jamie yes doctor
yes i think we should become doctors i
just became one
i tried that for a while actually yeah
did you really yeah i don't know
i mean i never went to college though
did hunters thompson ever get an
honorary degree or did he just call
himself dr hunter's thompson
because he was calling himself doctor
same trick same thing
well bill cosby became a doctor for a
little bit they took it back though
that's you know you [ __ ] up yeah yeah
yeah they take back your fake doctor
degree
yeah so this guy was like you know my
friend's like what do you think maxine
i'm like alright dr ken
i would have to consider i'm not sure
that i would do it but i would consider
taking this boat for free i'd have to
think about it but i would consider that
you know
and he's like i might be minimal to that
you know
so we've gone from like you know 500 to
free uh
and so we got this boat you know and it
was
something we had to do with the metal
and all this stuff we got the boat and
um
we were just trying to do like a little
um
we're just trying to anchor it did you
bring life vests
yeah i was wearing a a pfd yeah
type 2 pfd and
we took it we took it to this boat ramp
and it was the end of the day and the
wind was blowing kind of hard and
the conditions weren't that good but i
was like oh we're just doing this little
thing this little maneuver
and we were in two boats i built this
little wooden uh rowing boat
uh and my friend was going to go out in
that with one anchor and i was going to
sail out
yeah out of plywood it's stitching glue
but yeah
and but it you know not the sturdiest
vessel so uh
and so you know he's gonna go out in
this little row boat and i was gonna
sail out this
uh this little catamaran and we had two
anchors and we're gonna anchor and we're
gonna get in the row boat and roll back
and um it seemed a little windy and you
know i got in
the boat first and i got out around this
pier and was hit by the full force of
the wind and realized that it was
blowing like 20 knots was way
way too much for what we were trying to
do but i had mis-rigged part of the boat
so it took me a while to get it turned
around
um and by the time i got it turned
around my friend had rode out
um around the pier and he got hit by the
force of the wind and just got blown out
into the bay
so he's rowing directly into the wind
and moving backwards
oh [ __ ] out of the bay and i was like
[ __ ] and i'm on this little hobie cat
and
it was moving so fast like it was way
too windy to be sailing this thing
i've got just my clothes on i don't have
a wetsuit on or anything like that i
have a life jacket and just my clothes
and we don't have a radio we you know
we're unprepared
it's starting to get dark we don't have
a light um
and i'm sailing back and forth trying to
like help my friend
uh and it got to the point where i was
like all right i'm just gonna
tack over i'm gonna sail up uh to
this boat that was called the sea laos
sail up to the sea laos
i'm gonna get my friend off of it we're
just gonna abandon it and then we're
gonna sail this hobie cat back
if we can and so i go to turn around and
right as i'm turning around
a gust of wind hit the boat and capsized
it before i could even know that it was
happening you know just
it's just like you just it's one moment
you're on the boat the next moment
you're in the water you know
and the water was like 50 degrees um
like super
uh it like is a shock you know it hits
you
and the boat was a little messed up in a
way where
it i couldn't write it uh it capsized
and then the whole
it capsized all the way in and sank and
so it was floating like
[ __ ] like you know three feet under
water basically
um and so i'm in the water but i'm like
still i'm like a little bit out of the
water but like in the water
and you know i had a cell phone that
just immediately was
busted um and i look at my friend and
he's a ways away now
and he didn't see me and i was
you know yelling as loud as i could but
the wind is blowing 20 knots and it just
you know just you can't hear each other
you know
just takes your takes your voice away
and um he just i mean i was screaming i
was waving he wasn't wearing his glasses
uh and he just very slowly rode away oh
my god
and so then i was just like floating
there was starting to get dark um you
know he rode away did he notice that
your boated cap's eyes no he didn't even
see me he
he thought that i just sailed somewhere
else you know because in his mind
he was i was the person with the
experience do you still talk to this
dude yeah all the time yeah i feel like
you [ __ ]
i don't blame him in his mind he was the
person that was in trouble right you
know
and i understand and he thought i just
sailed somewhere else but that's crazy
yeah sailed out of vision yeah and then
you know it
basically got dark i could see the shore
it wasn't far away there's nobody on
shore there's nobody around
and um the wind was blowing directly
offshore so you have to swim
you know swim into the wind uh into the
wind wave and all that stuff
and um eventually i tried swimming and i
swam you know directly
upwind and i was because i was i was
like okay like if i get separated from
this boat and i don't make it to shore
then i'm definitely dead you know like
there's just no saving me uh so i was
trying to go directly upwind so that if
i felt like i couldn't make it i would
float back down one and hit the boat
again
and so i tried you know i swam for
probably like 20 minutes upwind and made
no progress
it didn't feel like any progress you
know my you know in 50 degrees you have
30 to 60 minutes before you black out
my arms were just you know it's like i
consider myself a strong swimmer
like i free dive you know stuff and i
just
you know it's like you read these
stories about uh
how people die you know of just like
they succumb to hypothermia on a local
hike or they drown in the bay you know
and the story is always like well timmy
was a strong swimmer but he and you're
like really was timmy really a strong
swimmer because he drowned in the bed
you know
and like floating there you know it just
all came to me i'm like wow this is how
this happens
you know you just make a series of
pretty dumb small decisions
until you find yourself like floating in
the dark in the bay there's no one
around
oh [ __ ] and it's a really slow process
too you know it's like
it's not like you know you just come to
terms with the idea that like you're not
gonna make it
and it's not it's not sudden it's not
like someone
shot you or you got hit by a bus or
something like that it's like
this hour long thing that you're getting
dragged through all alone
and you realize like no one will ever
even know
what this was you know how this happened
and you think about all the people like
joshua slocum jim gray people who are
lost at sea and you realize they all had
this
thing that they went through this
hour-long ordeal of just floating alone
and no one will even ever know what that
was or what that was like you know
and uh eventually i realized i was gonna
make it short i looked back
the boat was like way far away from me i
started you know drifting back towards
it i was still trying to swim
i realized at some point that i wasn't
going to hit it i wasn't going to hit
the boat on the way back downwind
and i had to just give it all that i had
to
try to connect with the boat you know to
stop myself from getting blown past it
and in that moment too you realize that
like
uncertainty is the most unendurable
condition you know that like
you imagine yourself making it to shore
and relaxing you know just knowing
that it's resolved right and in that
moment of like i might not make it back
to this boat you're
you're like tempted to give up because
it's the same
resolution you know it's the feeling of
just knowing
you know the uncertainties have been
resolved you know and you have to really
remind yourself that it's not the same
you know that like
you have to give it everything you have
in order to survive you know that that
feeling that you're
sort of longing for is not actually the
feeling that you want you know
uh and i just barely got the the end of
a rope that was trailing off
the the back of the hole pulled myself
back on it almost threw up
um then i had to then i was just
floating there with the with
the hole you know three feet underwater
i tied myself to it
um i started to get tunnel vision and
really at the last minute
um ice a tugboat uh
started uh coming through the area and
it was coming straight at me actually
and i i realized that it probably just
wouldn't even see me it would just
run me over and not even know that
i had been there you know it's totally
possible um and i was just you know i
was trying to like wave i could barely
lift my arm i was trying to scream i
could barely
make any noise and somehow they saw me
and uh
they they like it took them like 15
minutes to like get a rope around me and
they started pulling me up the side of
the boat and it was like
lining every tugboat is um tires like
tires
usually um as like a fender you know and
i got like
wedged in the tires as they were like
pulling me up and i knew what was
happening you know and i was like all i
have to do
is stick my leg out and push against the
whole of the boat
you know to like go around the tires and
i couldn't do it wow
uh and i knew and i could barely see and
they like swung me around and eventually
pulled me up
they like put me in uh next to the
engines in the engine room i couldn't
you know i couldn't even feel the heat
uh
and they called the coast guard and the
coast guard came and got me it was like
really embarrassing and
the coast guard like you know the coast
guard guys like
you know he's like god these blankets
over me he's like trying to like talk to
me to like keep me
like alert you know and uh and
you know he's like so is this is this
your first time sailing
and i have like a commercial like a 250
ton like master's license
you know like it's like you need 600
days at sea to get this license you know
uh and i was like no i i have a master's
license and he was like
what i think you're a [ __ ] idiot man
you know like
everything changed the tone totally
changed you know oh my god dude that's
insane
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download
episodes to save on data cost all for
free
spotify is absolutely free you don't
have to have a premium account to watch
new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience